just the other day samsung accidentally
leaked their upcoming flagship galaxy
tab s8 ultra tablet on their own website
and if that wasn't bad enough it
apparently comes with a notch yes a
notch and i don't know if you remember
or not but samsung has been making fun
of apple's notch for years ever since
the iphone 10 and even as recent as last
year when they made fun of the new
macbook pros notch but thanks to these
new leaked images it's pretty clear that
samsung was ironically working on a
notched tablet of their own the entire
time and if you think it couldn't get
any worse they actually leak the specs
of each of the different tab sa models
by posting actual listings to amazon
with official images of each model and
the folks over at android authority were
nice enough to compile a chart with all
of the specs and to be completely honest
if these are the actual specs that these
tablets will come with then i think
there's a pretty good chance that the
tab s8 ultra is gonna fail at least
compared to apple's m1 ipad pro which is
soon going to be a full year old not to
mention their upcoming m2 ipad pro
coming later this year so in this video
i'm going to be comparing the leak specs
and features of the tap sa ultra to what
we already have with the m1 ipad pro to
show how samsung's new tablet is more
behind than ever before now the first
thing i want to mention is that there is
going to be three different sizes
including an 11 inch lcd model a 12.7
inch amoled model and finally the new
14.6 inch ultra which is the one that's
coming with the notch and the reason for
that is because it apparently comes with
a secondary 12 megapixel selfie camera
which probably uses an ultra wide lens
and looking at the official product
images that samsung leaked on amazon the
tab s8 and s8 plus look essentially
identical to the design of the previous
tab s7 which we already compared to the
m1 ipad pro and since the leaked display
specs on the new tab s8 plus model is
literally identical to the one in the
tab s7 plus i'll actually be able to
show you guys the differences in display
quality from our previous comparison
video but before we get into all of that
i want to compare some of the other
specs that were leaked especially the
new chip unlike last year every tab is 8
model will now come with 8 gigs of ram
which perfectly matches up to both
models of the ipad pro and the ultra
model will now be able to come with up
to 16 gigs just like the m1 can and now
as far as the storage space both the
regular and plus models will come with
128 gigs of base storage just like the
ipad pro except that the ultra model
will now come with
256 gigs at the base price which is
actually pretty nice however the leaked
amazon listing showed a price of around
13.08 euros for the 5g model which
converts to around 14.79 usd
which is actually more expensive than a
similarly spec 12.9 inch ipad pro with
256 gigs of storage and 5g cellular
supports but keep in mind that the tab
sa ultra will have a larger 14.6 inch
display so i guess the big question is
if you're gonna be paying more money for
a samsung android tablet than an ipad
pro
what benefits are you getting other than
the larger display size well first of
all the s pen is going to be included
compared to having to buy the apple
pencil separately for the ipad but
unfortunately it's been confirmed that
samsung has not upgraded the s pen at
all since the last generation another
benefit is that the battery size on the
tab s8 ultra will be around four percent
larger than the one that's in the 12.9
inch ipad pro and one more advantage
that i really wish the m1 ipad pro had
is the latest bluetooth 5.2 and wi-fi 6e
supports on all of the tab s8 models
which should be a nice bonus and then as
far as the cameras it's a hit or miss
because the ultra comes with two selfie
cameras both packed with 12 megapixel
sensors which is going to be nice for
both close-up shots and ultra wide but
then when you get to the rear the
ultrawide camera only has 6 megapixel
resolution compared to 12 on the ipad
pro but at least the main camera has 13
megapixels on the rear instead of 12 on
the ipad but now getting into the major
downsides of these new tap s8 tablets
the usbc ports only support usb 3.2 gen
1 speeds which means transfer speeds of
only 5 gigabits per second compared to
the m1 ipad pro which comes with a
thunderbolt port with speeds up to 40
gigabits per second which is 8 times
faster so that's already something that
should get potential buyers thinking
since the ipad pro has such a huge
advantage in terms of the port but going
further every new tab s8 model including
the ultra is coming with the same
snapdragon 8 gen 1 chip which let me
remind you is a smartphone chip and if
you're wondering how powerful this chip
is compared to apple's m1 and the ipad
pro let me first show you how it
compares to apple's lower end iphone
chips and this brings us to a snapdragon
8 gen 1 chip review video from geekerwan
who according to the title
don't think too fondly of this new chip
compared to the previous snapdragon 888
the new chip is only 1.5 faster in terms
of geekbench 5 multi-core performance
and only around 5.7 faster for single
core and the crazy thing about it is
that it's slower than the three year old
a13 chip from the iphone 11. yes let me
repeat that the brand new snapdragon 8
gen 1 going into the new flagship galaxy
tab s8 ultra has less single core
performance than the iphone 11's a13
channel but to make things even worse
this new snapdragon chip consumes
considerably more power than apple's a14
and a15 chips while being a lot slower
as you can see on the right side where
it shows the score per watt and in case
you're wondering how it compares to the
m1 chip within the eight month old ipad
pro the m1 is about 42.5 faster in terms
of single core and literally almost
twice as fast in terms of multi-core but
thankfully things over on the graphics
side are a little bit better since the
snapdragon's gpu actually compared to
the lower end version of the new a15
when using the vulkan api which is
pretty impressive however looking at the
power consumption it uses 72 percent
more power than that same four core a15
ship leading to a pretty terrible
performance per watt score but then once
again when we compare it to the m1 ipad
pro there is a massive difference with
the m1 scoring 82 fps in the 1440p test
and 210 in the 1080p test making it 60
to 70 faster than the snapdragon 8 gen
1. so as you guys can see the upcoming
galaxy tab s8 ultra is no match for
apple's m1 ipad pro especially in the
multi-core performance department but
now the last saving grace for the
samsung tablet is the amoled display so
let's revisit our comparison of the tab
s7 plus and the 12.9 inch m1 ipad pro
one of the downsides of samsung's
display is that it's very reflective so
it causes it to look great instead of
being a very deep and dark black like on
the ipad pro and when you're holding it
up to your and what and when you're
holding it and when you're holding it up
to your face the samsung display almost
looks like a mirror compared to barely
anything being visible on the ipad and
then in terms of hdr brightness the mini
led display on the ipad pro looks
incredibly bright compared to the gray
looking samsung however the mini led
tech did suffer from blooming in this
fireworks scene compared to amoled that
looks much better with no blooming at
all so there's a point for the samsung
tablet but with all that said the specs
of the new tab s8 just can't compare
with the m1 ipad pro especially in terms
of performance and usbc port speeds and
that's even before we get into the
differences in resale value reliability
and the app store and this was honestly
the year where samsung needed to show a
huge improvement in order to catch up to
apple's m1 ipad pro but in my opinion
they have failed and this is all really
bad news for when apple releases their
m2 ipad pro later this year which will
take it up another notch so if you're
interested in seeing samsung's new
tablet go heads ahead with apple's m1
ipad pro here in the next few weeks
click that circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one and check out
one of those two videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]